today we're going to look at Mendeleev a
Russian chemist from the 19th century in
1869 he first presented his periodic
table which is shown on the screen here
to a big audience of scientists and many
of them actually laughed him off the
stage and he was very disturbed by this
however his periodic table is largely
unchanged for the one that we see in
today's chemistry books and he was a
true genius to put his periodic table
together
what Mendeleev did was he decided to
organize his periodic table of elements
and at the time there were only 50
elements known he organized his periodic
table by looking at their mass so you
can see at the start he had hydrogen
then lithium beryllium boron carbon
nitrogen oxygen fluorine going across
but also when he started to arrange them
he noticed patterns starting to occur so
he noticed that when he arranged them in
this particular sequence that the
elements in each column had similar
chemical properties so for instance he
noticed that in the first column all of
the elements reacted with water to
produce oxides so not only did his
periodic table show the order of
elements by mass but also we showed that
they have similar chemical properties in
each particular column other things that
came out from his periodic table was
that sometimes he noticed that elements
were actually in the wrong order and he
switched them round this is a particular
stroke of genius because there are some
elements whose masses don't correspond
to their atomic number and this is
because they may have slightly more
neutrons they may have different
isotopes and the result is that overall
when you measure them they give a
heavier mass than you'd expect he
overlooked this and I've just popped
them in based on their properties so his
periodic table was arranged by mass
and that's important to realize that's
mass not mass number but he arranged
them by their mass and he linked that
into their properties another stroke of
genius by Mendeleev was to realize that
although he had 50 elements that there
may well be some elements not discovered
in other words some missing elements and
as a result he had the sense to leave
some spaces on his periodic table these
spaces indicated here as the asterixis
however because he knew that these
elements had similar properties to the
ones that were around them in the same
column and also he noticed that there
were already patterns developing in
terms of their physical properties he
was able to predict particular
properties now in specific this element
here which we now know to be germanium
Mendeleev he called it eka silicon and
he predicted that it had particular
properties he predicted its density its
mass and how it would react and when
germanium was in finally discovered they
didn't find in fact find that it had
very similar properties so those
predicted by Mendeleev now there are
still some differences between our
modern periodic table and our modern
periodic table is actually organized by
atomic number not mass or mass number
and in addition there is a whole group
of elements that are not mentioned on
Mendeleev's periodic table at all and
those are the noble gases or group 8 and
that's because these gases were
discovered very late on because of
course although their gases and are in
the air around us they do not react
and so therefore you don't find the many
Ning compounds and they were unaware
that they existed until into the 20th
century so there is a whole group eight
that does not appear on the end of
Mendeleev's periodic table so in summary
Mendeleev was not the first person but
the first person to put together a
periodic table that is very similar to
the one that we use today in chemistry
he organized it by mass and identified
patterns within the properties of the
elements that he put into his particular
periodic table because of this he was
able to identify gaps in his periodic
table and predict the properties of the
elements that were delayed to be
discovered to fill these gaps the modern
periodic table differs from Mendeleev in
that it is ordered by the atomic number
and has the noble gases which were not
present at all in Mendeleev's periodic
table